not only are we here as part of cnas's
annual conference but even more
importantly sorry Richard we are
celebrating the podcast five-year
anniversary and Jim and I thought there
was no better way to celebrate brussels
sprouts as the anniversary then by
bringing back the co-founder the
co-creator of Brussels sprouts
Ambassador Julie Smith who as our
listeners know has gone on to much
bigger things in her current role as the
U.S ambassador to Nato so Julie
Ambassador Smith
um welcome back to Brussels sprouts uh
so then Jim and I were thinking if we're
bringing in Ambassador Smith back to the
podcast how are we going to really outdo
ourselves and take things over the top
to make this a special celebration to
really remember and the answer to that
question was crystal clear uh we knew we
had to bring back to Brussels sprouts
NATO secretary Yan stoltenberg I think
someone who encapsulates the spirit and
strength of the transatlantic Alliance
so without further Ado I am really
excited to welcome back to Brussels
sprouts as Secretary General Jens
sultanburg
um it's such an honor to have you join
us today and I think just looking at
this screen I'm overwhelmed and I have
to see I can't think of a better way to
Mark the anniversary of the podcast
um and I want to point out Secretary
General that you were on the podcast
back in 2017 so I think in a sense we've
really brought things full circle for
the five-year anniversary so this is
really fantastic and I'm really looking
forward to our conversation so I want to
jump right in one quick note before I do
I want to let all of the listeners know
that you can also submit questions for
the Secretary General and Ambassador
Smith
so if you have a question and you want
to hear it included as part of our
podcast recording please use the chat
box at
cnes.org forward slash live or tweet at
us using the hashtag cnas2023
okay Secretary General I'd love to start
with you and I want to start our
discussion where I think our listeners
are entirely focused and that is on
Ukraine's offensive many indicators just
indicate that it has started and we know
that there's really a lot at stake in
many ways it will be Ukraine's ability
to retake territory and to demonstrate
that it can use Western Equipment to go
to fact that will shape future levels of
support for Kiev but I also think we
understand
um and there that there's a good chance
that the offensive will not be decisive
meaning that we can't necessarily expect
that it will push Putin to the
negotiating table and bring an end to
the war and so my question is can you
tell us about the West long-term plan to
support Ukraine and how you see NATO's
role in that
but let me I will say some words about
in a moment let me first thank you for
having me on this podcast and it's great
to be back and a great honor to be here
together with Ambassador Julie Smith
because I was actually not aware that
she was a co-founder of this podcast so
that makes it there even a greater
pleasure to to be here to celebrate the
the fifth anniversary and and I think it
is important that we have podcasts like
this one too to do to ensure that there
is focus uh a platform to discuss and to
address the importance of the
transatlantic bone and how we ensure
that that prevails and is actually
strengthened in the more dangerous world
and and Ambassador Smith she she really
demonstrates her leadership and her
commitment to this uh Alliance every day
here at NATO so we are glad that she's
not working with you but actually work
with us here at uh here at NATO then
on the offensive well what you have seen
is that there is now more fighting going
on along the front lines
um I'm always very careful not going
into the operational details because I
think that's really for the ukrainians
uh to to tell and you're also seeing
this video they have put out on the
social media I would actually calling on
everyone to be to don't say so much
about the the the the counter offensive
the the operational details uh um
and then of course Wars are
unpredictable so no one can tell exactly
how this will evolve what we do know is
that the ukrainians have now
capabilities weapons ammunition and also
training provided by NATO allies and
partners and at least to the U.S led
contact group for Ukraine that has put
them in a place so they they have their
capabilities needed to liberate more
land and what we also know is that the
ukrainians have proven and that they are
able to push back the Russian forces as
they did in the north around Kiev just
after a few weeks in the East around
harkiv and then in the Southern and now
there are more equipment more training
and more preparations for uh liberating
even more land no one can tell exactly
how this war ends but what we do know is
that
what happens around a negotiating table
that uh some stage hopefully will bring
an end to this war it's totally
dependent on what goes on on the
battlefield so we need to strengthen
Ukraine's position on the battlefield to
enable them to get an outcome of this
war which
ensures that Ukraine prevails as a
certain independent nation and that
President Putin do not win this war
thank you
thank you Thad and I realize that you've
probably been asked that question
multiple times that's uh so it's a
well-honed answer that's very excellent
but I have a question for both of you uh
for Julie it's from the U.S perspective
and then Mr Secretary General from the
alliance perspective but you probably
know here on the streets in Washington
uh as we think about Vilnius the big
question is what will NATO do in terms
of security guarantees for Ukraine we
know that zielinski has particularly
been uh going around talking about NATO
membership uh having been in NATO myself
I know that's not exactly how it works
is this is for uh Ukraine this is
something and for NATO it's very
sensitive uh on next steps but but
everyone seems to agree that we need to
do something in terms of security
guarantees between now uh and the time
when uh they can be brought into the
alliance if that's the alliance decision
that when they can be brought in uh
there's got to be some type of security
guarantees backed up by the West so at
Vilnius how you all going to handle that
Mr Secretary General what's what's the
approach going to be in talking about
security guarantees and Julie Ambassador
Smith in terms of the United States
where's the U.S when security guarantees
first
for NATO security guarantees are Article
5 is full membership then I know that
there are also uh discussions
um and consultations uh between Ukraine
and some allies on bilateral
Arrangements but I will not go into
those uh what I can say what can what I
can address is is the the ongoing
process in in NATO and yes there are
consultations on these issues on how to
address Ukraine's membership aspirations
and we had a very good foreign minister
meeting in Oslo uh just a few days ago
where this was one of the main topics
and of course we this too early to
preempt the outcome of the William
Summit on this issue but what I can say
is that allies actually agree on many
important things related to uh to uh to
to Ukraine and the path towards NATO
membership because all allies agree that
NATO's door is open and we demonstrated
that over the last series with North
Macedonia Montenegro and now by inviting
Finland and Sweden and Finland has
already become a full-fledged member of
the alliance so NATO's door remains open
that's the and all allies agree second
all allies agree that Ukraine will
become a member of the alliance that has
been stated again and again last time
all leaders stated that at the Madrid
Summit in in June last year
and then all allies also agree that it
is for Ukraine and for the Allies to
decide when the time is right to invite
Ukraine to become a member it's not for
Moscow it's not for a Putin Putin
doesn't have a veto over NATO
enlargement and then we agree on one
more thing and that is also vitally
important and that is that the most
urgent task now is to ensure that
President Putin do not does not win this
war and and that Ukraine pervades
Because unless Ukraine is able to
continue to exist as a Sovereign
independent Democratic state in Europe
there is no issue to discuss about
membership at all so we should not do
anything now that undermines the unity
in providing support to Ukraine and
again I'd like to commend the United
States for really showing leadership in
in mobilizing support both from the
United States but also from European
allies and from Partners across the
world
um the reason why we need to address the
issue of
security arrangements assurances and
also at some stage membership is that
when this war ends
we we have to have uh
Arrangements in place that ensure that
this is just not a kind of a pause where
President Putin is able to rest and
reconstitute and re-locate its forces
for yet another attack as we have seen
for many years the award didn't start
last year it started in in 2014 and
therefore when this war ends we need to
have the framework in place to ensure
that history doesn't repeat itself that
President Putin not to continue to chip
away at European security by attacking
Ukraine and in that broader framework of
course all kinds of Arrangements
Frameworks that ensures and helps to
prevent further attacks on on Ukraine is
of great importance
yeah Julie baby just to reframe the
question over to you as Jim said to hear
the U.S perspective I think one concern
is if we all agree that Ukraine should
eventually be in NATO we're talking
about after the war and so the concern
is well if Putin understands that that's
not happening until quote unquote after
the war then he has every incentive to
continue the war as long as possible and
so I wonder if you can talk a little bit
about whether there is thinking and what
the thinking is about whether or not
there are interim steps that Washington
might consider taking in terms of these
security assurances or other things that
could be put in place even while
fighting is ongoing
uh well first of all let me just say uh
congratulations to the Brussels sprouts
team Andrea and Jim it's been an
incredible run I can't believe uh five
years support have gone by
um and I've really genuinely enjoyed
listening from here in Brussels to
Brussels sprouts so uh congrats on all
of that and thanks for the invitation
today it's such a treat to do this uh in
tandem with the Secretary General on the
question of Ukraine and its future
relationship with the alliance the
question of security assurances slash
guarantees I mean all I can do is uh in
essence Echo what the Secretary General
just said we are as you might imagine uh
you both have worked many years in
government this is the time when we are
sitting around the table working on a
package for the summit you've heard that
President zielinski intends to come in
person and we are working on several
things simultaneously we're looking at
how to end enhance our practical support
not just in terms of what allies provide
right now so that the ukrainians can
continue to retake territory but we're
really trying to send a signal to Russia
and our friends in Ukraine that
irrespective of when this war comes to
an end NATO allies will continue to stay
on shoulder to shoulder with Ukraine to
help with its long-term modernization
with interoperability with questions of
standardization and a whole array of
things that will signal to Ukraine that
it is both about support to you now and
it's about support to you in the future
and I think that message is going to
come across loud and clear and Vilnius
the other part of the package is on the
political front you've heard and read in
the press that we're looking at an array
of options to also signal that the
ukrainians are advancing in their
relationship with the NATO alliance and
the alliance is interested in
strengthening their political
relationship with the Allies represented
Around The Knack table and so we're
looking at some possibilities there the
bigger question about how we capture
membership in the communique will be
something we will debate in the weeks
ahead where about five weeks out and as
you well know there are a variety of
views across the alliance we have the
ukrainians themselves asking for a
proper invitation we have some allies
that are looking at Bucharest from 2008
and feel comfortable with that and in
between is a lot of gray space and I
think over the next five weeks we are
going to find the place where we can
address Ukraine's concerns we can signal
to the Ukrainian people that NATO is
interested in this relationship for the
Long Haul and that Russia will not
succeed in getting all of us to look
away obviously Putin thought we would
eventually get distracted and lose
interest in Ukraine but we can say
sitting here in the halls of NATO that's
not happening and unity remains firm of
course we have our challenges at times
with all of the assistance that's being
provided that obviously gets harder
um each and every week that takes by but
the commitment to keep supporting
Ukraine so that they can ultimately
Prevail is Rock Solid and will be able
to send that message loud and clearer in
Vilnius wonderful thanks thanks to both
Secretary General I want to ask you a
little bit of a spicy question
um some critics out there have said or
some voices out there have said that
NATO was brain dead and that it was
Vladimir Putin that revitalized the
drifting Alliance
um the argument would be that it wasn't
really until the re-invasion that the
alliance became truly attuned to the
threats that Russia poses I have my own
views but I want to put it to you to
hear was it NATO or was it NATO members
some NATO members that were brain dead
ahead of the invasion
NATO was very much aware of this
Invasion that that Russia was planning
and building up for an innovation of uh
of the the of of Ukraine uh because uh
the United States all the NATO allies
and also NATO uh took part in in the
efforts of sharing information to to
share with the broader public that
actually now President Putin Russia was
planning for a full-scale invasion of
the Ukraine and and this was made public
in the fall of 2021 but more important
than actually sharing that information
which was I think very important
NATO has seen a pattern for many years
and we have responded to that because
again it didn't start in in February
2022 it started in Ukraine in in in in
the spring of 2014 and since 2014 with
the first illegal annexation Crimea and
then a few weeks later the the Russia uh
taking control over Eastern and Don boss
NATO has implemented over all these nine
years now the biggest adaptation on the
lines in NATO's modern history with more
combatuated troops for the first time in
our history combat or battle groups in
eastern part of the alliance that's
something we agreed in 2016. after some
discussions but we actually made that
decision and then before 2014 all
analysts were reducing defense spending
of the 2014 all allies across Europe and
Canada and of course the United States
leading defense spending has increased
or have increased defense spending
significantly added 250 billion extra
dollars across Europe and and Canada
and then we have established new defense
domains like cyber and so on so so so so
NATO's NATO is the most successful in
history Alliance in history for two
reasons first our Unity but the second
reason is that we have been able to
change when the world is changing for 40
years we deterred Russia or the Soviet
Union and the washer pact then the the
Cold War ended and and and and we helped
to end the ethnic wars in the Balkans in
Boston Serbia Kosovo then after 9 11
we're on the front line in in the fight
against terrorism and then over the last
years especially since 2014 we have
turned away from what I say big Auto
area operations to really build up
Collective defense
in Europe so when The Invasion happened
last year the full-scale invasion
happened last year NATO was was prepared
partly because we had shared
intelligence but also partly because we
had already
implemented this big biggest adaptation
of the alliance uh uh in in decades so
so so so NATO continues to adapt that's
the reason why we are successful and
that adaptation didn't start last year
it started actually in 2014 after the
illegal annexation of Crimea
well thank you very much the history you
recited is so familiar and it's a great
story of particularly moving from the
Wales Summit to what we'll see in
Vilnius I'm sure and then the Washington
Summit coming up too is going to be a
trajectory that I think none of us saw
you know 20 years ago two and a half
years ago and yet there we are but I
tell you what you've laid out is a is a
is a story of NATO adaptation that is
really uh been strong and I just hope
that that will continue after Vilnius
into the future that we can keep that
momentum going but let me take us to
another part of your your aor your era
responsibility that's cropped up uh and
that's the Balkans uh and uh that's
really actually a reminder to our
listeners that it's not all about Russia
Ukraine we've got problems uh in Europe
in the South as well uh we have violence
uh breakouts and even worse uh a worse
way a couple of days ago NATO
peacekeepers were hurt uh that looks
like Kosovo and the Serbian governments
are spoiling for a fight and NATO's in
the middle of that too and I'm sure that
you and Ambassador Smith got phone calls
in the middle of the night uh saying
we've got to do something so let me ask
both of you both from the United States
perspective Ambassador Smith what uh
what Washington is trying to do about
the situation but particularly at NATO
uh dealing with K4 how are things
looking in terms of the way ahead for
dealing with the Balkans
well uh first of all thanks for the
reminder because of course you're right
we often talk about a 360 degree
approach around here inside the NATO
alliance which means we have to be
prepared to deal with any potential
threats challenges crises that come at
us from all angles not just in regards
to what's going on in Ukraine which is
our top priority but in places like the
Balkans and you're right in recent days
we've seen some violence we had a couple
of dozen of k-4 soldiers serving there
as part of the NATO presence injured
some seriously injured immediately we
set to work inside here at the NATO
alliance and working individually
messaging our friends both in Kosovo and
Serbia that we wanted the violence to
end we wanted an immediate de-escalation
and that the only path forward is the
eu-led dialogue the EU facilitated
dialogue and here it's it's quite
interesting because says you have this
NATO presence on the ground in the
Balkans and yet it is the EU that is
laying out the path forward towards no
normalization which we believe is the
only path that you can take so this is
an interesting Dynamic where both the EU
and NATO are heavily engaged and
involved we've had several folks travel
down into the region just over the last
couple of days both from Europe and the
United States we're working hand in
glove but it's a good reminder that
we're on our toes that NATO has a
presence in other parts of the continent
also has a mission in Iraq by the way
that sometimes folks I think forget or
don't don't adequately appreciate so we
are focused on this we do obviously
don't want to see any sort of conflict
emerge here any more violence and we are
focused on it like a laser and it is a
reminder that NATO is on the ground and
playing an active role there in
providing Security in the western
Balkans
let me just briefly say that first of
all I agree with everything Ambassador
Smith just said about the Balkans and
and NATO's role but two more things one
is that I think uh what happens in
Kosovo in particular but those in
Western Balkans in general uh
demonstrates the value and the
importance of NATO e working together
and we really do that for instance also
we have the NATO troops we have the K4
troops supporting and facilitating the
Diplomatic efforts of the European Union
and that's really an example of how we
can work together in addressing a common
challenge in our common uh neighborhood
then of course the attacks on the K4
forces is absolutely unacceptable and we
have also
reinforced our presence with uh several
hundred 700 extra forces from our
operational Reserve mainly Turkish
forces to to further strengthen our
presence in the in in a more tense and
difficult situation in
in the in Kosovo there are challenges
there are problems uh and and we have
seen some setbacks but let me also
remind you of that the fact that the
Western Balkans in in total is actually
also uh many there are also many success
stories I mean not so long in the 1990s
we have brutal ethnic Wars with
thousands of killed uh then NATO played
a key role in ending both those roles uh
both those Wars and then since then we
have had the presence in in in in Kosovo
military presence we have headquarters
in Sarajevo we have the political
engagement in the region and
several other Former Yugoslav republics
which are now independent nations are
members of NATO of course both Slovenia
and and Croatia for many years but in
most more recently Montenegro and North
North Macedonia so so yes there are
problems and the ends there are all
unsolved issues but but but I've been I
spent a lot of time in Montenegro and
North Macedonia because they became
members during my tenure as sector
General and and and the and and what
this has made for those countries by the
way it has helped to to to to move them
towards integration in the Atlantic
family and also help to facilitate
Investments Prosperity a more stable
framework for also economic growth has
been enormous so so we should also
appreciate all the progress that has
been made while we of course continue to
address the unsolved attentions and
issues yeah that's a great question Jim
because it does remind that there's
multiple challenge challenges that NATO
has to deal with simultaneously and
maybe we can touch on some of those in a
second the China question resilience
critical infrastructure all of those
things but
we those challenges are balanced against
like the the acute challenge that Russia
poses and I want to ask then Secretary
General about how NATO is thinking about
right sizing the Russia challenge you
know secretary blinken was um out just
recently saying that Russia has the
second strongest military in just
Ukraine and so I wonder do you hear
anything from allies about well if the
Russian military can't even be
successful and defeat Ukraine then why
is it that you're asking us to increase
defense spending
um I just want to ask you know when when
you're thinking about right sizing the
challenge we don't want to overestimate
it because it takes away resources and
attention from the other critical
challenges that Neato has to address so
how do you think about the appropriate
level of military resources to devote
against
um to devote to defending against Russia
moving forward
we live in a more dangerous world we
have a Russia as a neighbor which has
been willing to use military force
against neighbors not once but several
times over the last days starting
actually with Georgia in 2008 uh we have
terrorism we have uh nuclear perforation
and then we don't regard China as a
threat but but China is investing
heavily in new modern capabilities
including uh more and more advanced and
long-range nuclear missiles so so all
this instability and all these
challenges just makes it necessary for
us to invest more in defense and we have
to remember that until the end of the
Cold War the average in Europe was
roughly three percent of GDP for defense
and now we are also we are still not at
two as an average so so it's not that
much we are asking for we are asking to
to off the end of the Cold War we reduce
defense spending and one way I
understand that allies reduce defense
spending I did that myself as a Minister
of Finance in Norway in the 1990s but
when if you reduce the fan spending
intentions are going down you have to be
able to increase the defense spending
intentions are going up and two percent
is not actually that that much the
reality is that there's a minimum to to
to pay for all the capabilities and the
forces uh we uh we uh we need and uh and
second I think yes uh Russia has
suffered or has has paid the high price
for for the brutal invasion of Ukraine
and President Putin made several big
strategic mistakes when he invaded uh
Ukraine one was to talk to underestimate
the ukrainians The Bravery the Kurdish
their ability to fight back the other
big mistake was to understand NATO and
and NATO allies and partners in our
resolve to support Ukraine to Stand
United and to stand by Ukraine for as
long as it takes and again the U.S has
really demonstrated leadership
in a way that has inspired all those to
to to to to step up
um and then I think also president talk
to underestimated the political impact
on countries like Finland and Sweden he
wanted less NATO is getting more NATO on
his borders with Finland and Sweden but
we should not make the mistake to
underestimate Russia because what they
what they lack in in quality in they
have bad morale bad equipment Bad
training bad leadership Logistics but
what they lack in quality they
compensate in quantity and quantity has
a quality in itself as the generals keep
on telling us
and and we see that immobilizing more
forces we also know that they have had
big losses for the land forces but they
have air and Naval forces which have as
I hardly suffered any losses of a few
losses with some exemptions and then
they have cyber and then of course
Russia remains a nuclear power so so we
should not make make the mistake to
underestimate the Russian this and even
when the fighting stops in Ukraine this
will have a long lasting consequences
for the security in Europe and and we
need to invest more in defense in a more
dangerous world
in just a few a few weeks
um my understanding is uh from what I've
heard on the street is that uh NATO
plans to roll out uh or at least talk
about this big uh military operational
plan which is going to require Nations
to put more forces forward and uh and do
a lot of things uh that we should be
doing in a situation like this
militarily but that will be expensive uh
and so at Vilnius will there be changes
at all to the uh to the the various
commitments that we want Nations to make
uh I.E 2 should be a floor not a ceiling
we want Nations to go up to three and a
half percent
uh sanctions if the Nations don't I'm
sure that's not going to happen but I
mean how are we going to get Nations to
pay not just for uh replenishing what
they've provided Ukraine or into make up
deficits that they already have but to
pay for a new plan uh that the military
authorities have been working on uh any
any any insight into what can happen in
Vilnius to try to get us that way will
the U.S pound the table uh Ambassador
Smith
we will without a doubt Jim continue to
press allies uh to meet the defense
investment pledge and there's going to
be a couple of different moving parts to
The Summit in Vilnius first and foremost
above and beyond the question of Ukraine
and NATO's relationship with Ukraine so
on deterrence and defense specifically
we're going to be rolling out new
Regional plans this is a big deal
because we're going to have plans in
place to protect every inch of NATO's
territory these are also going to be
multi-domain plans which is important
that includes other aspects like cyber
we're going to have a new C2 structure
that will be paired with the regional
plans and lastly we're going to say
something about resourcing which gets to
your point about what comes after the
defense investment pledge the dip as it
was designed in 2014 is you know better
than anybody else you were present at
the creation had a 10-year cap on it
next year it expires and so in Vilnius
this summer we'll be laying out kind of
dip 2.0 of where do we go from here I
think where allies are United at the
moment is focusing very much on ensuring
that two percent is an enduring
commitment it is a floor not a ceiling
and there will be language on this again
we're in the process of negotiating that
literally in real time here in NATO
headquarters with all of the Allies but
when you put all of this together when
you put the regional plans with the
force posture changes we made last year
by the way and adding foreign
multinational battalions when you add
that to the new C2 structure and the dip
2.0 we're going to be in a whole new
world in terms of the requirements that
allies will have to meet Clarity on what
the responsibilities are for each
individual Ally we're going to increase
the level of Readiness we're going to
have a bigger pool of forces from which
to draw but you're absolutely right it
will require countries to deliver on the
2 two percent now right now by any count
we have about seven or eight allies we
expect that number to be significantly
bigger next year in 2024 with more
coming in about 2025 2026 so there's
good news here on the resourcing front
but the United States will continue to
push and with the secretary General's
help in his leadership in ensuring that
all allies meet those resourcing
requirements so we can deliver on the
plans that we're rolling out in Vilnius
Julie quick follow-up in Secretary
General will come to you but um
can you talk to us a little bit about I
mean so obviously in the United States
China remains a key priority uh and a
central Focus so you've talked about the
how much that you know that the two
percent is a floor not a ceiling
um but then there's the question of how
allies are spending that money and I get
that the regional plans gets it some of
that but can you talk a little bit about
um and whether there are conversations
about NATO member states spending on
things that the United States might need
to draw down in the event that tensions
rise in the indo-pacific art is that
something that you think allies are
attuned to and that is driving
conversations about how allies should
spend
well here's what's driving the
conversation on that front it's largely
tied to the Strategic concept that was
rolled out last year and there we cite
two main threats as the Secretary
General previously noted it's Russia and
terrorism but what was really important
about that strategic concept was that it
included mention of the PRC for the
first time and that's important because
now all allies agree there is consensus
that these challenges mirrored our
attention and not just because of what
China is doing in its own neighborhood
but because of what China is doing in
and around the euro-atlantic
neighborhood we are talking increasingly
here at NATO about malicious cyber
attacks about disinformation about
malign influence about economic coercion
and attempts to in essence erode the
rules-based order or erode our
technological Edge and because of that
the alliance now is in the process of
fleshing out a variety of policies and
tools to cope with those challenges how
do we build resilience here how do we
protect critical infrastructure how do
we work with the European Union on cyber
attacks so this will be part of our
future agenda I know Jim referenced this
earlier for all the obvious reasons
Ukraine is the top order priority no
question about that but speaking to
NATO's adaptability the alliance is
simultaneously taking on new challenges
emerging in disruptive Technologies
there's a whole list here and that does
get us to the resourcing question to
acknowledge those challenges in the
Strategic concept pair them with the
threats of Russia and terrorism really
gets you to the point where you can
easily justify why this type of spending
is necessary
I would know we could continue down this
path for a while we don't have that many
minutes left and I know we want to add
uh and on with a couple of reflective
questions and Secretary General I just
wanted to ask you to look back at
um NATO's relations with Russia under
your tenure so I know you came into your
role in 2014 and relations had already
taken a very significant downward turn
but the US and Europe were never really
able to get things back on track and
maybe perhaps it was a little bit of the
lackluster response in 2014 that made
this current moment um more likely but
can I just ask you to reflect a little
bit on how things got so bad and whether
or not you think we had any missed
opportunities with Russia
NATO and the west and NATO allies we
really tried to create and to establish
a better relationship with Russia after
the end of the Cold War we established a
nato-russia council we had the founding
act between the NATO and and Russia and
and both as NATO but also as individual
allies in the United States of course
really made a lot of efforts uh in those
decades to really change our
relationship with uh with Russia and I
was part of that in my previous capacity
as a Norwegian politician for 10 years
also prime minister and and in Norway in
the high North we're actually able to to
develop good working relationships a
good cooperation with with Russia
as I met president pretty many times we
discussed everything from energy project
up in the baron sea to delimitation on
the negotiated and agreed in the policy
and the barons the
environment Fisheries we had a lot of
cooperation up in the north and I
strongly believed in the NATO idea of
the Terence defense and dialogue
and uh but but then Russia has
deliberately chosen all the path they
they they they they didn't they didn't
they didn't have the courage to really
engage and to try to build down
historical uh differences that has been
possible before the Nordic countries the
swedes and the Danes and the fins and
the Norwegians we used to fight for
centuries and now we're the best friends
in the world and if we look at the rest
of Europe the United Kingdom France
Germany they also used to get to be
different sides of wars that have
ravaged here for for centuries and now
their best friends and allies in NATO
and the European Union so of course you
could it was right to hope for something
similar to happen in our relationship
with Russia but then gradually we saw
that Russia was walking away
with
actions against the Georgia Ukraine and
other countries where they try to
re-establish spheres of influence where
big Nations control what the smaller
neighbors can do and then NATO gradually
of course need to emphasize more no
dialogue but the the tyrants and the
fence and any particular since since
2014 so you can always have a kind of
academic discussion and that's important
about what could have been different but
the overall picture is that we really
tried from from the NATO side to engage
with Russia Russia didn't have the I
think fundamentally what President Putin
really is afraid of it's not NATO but
he's afraid of free Democratic societies
which is undermining his power base in
Moscow and that's also the reason why I
don't want to see a successful free
independent Democratic Ukraine because
that really challenged his idea of uh
how to govern and Rule and to to remain
in power in in Russia yeah
last question and when Julie and I used
to do this she used to love the Jim
Townsend question at the end so I think
she probably knows what's was heading
your way but um but you know and this is
really for both of you and Mr Secretary
General starting with you you know this
you've you have just had a tremendous uh
tenure there at NATO for so many years
so many crises the book you write will
be multi-volumed and it'll be a great
movie Tom Cruise will play you and uh
and it'll be uh be a Academy Award
winner but but let me ask you as you are
looking at uh towards the end now of
your of your tenure
um what advice do you wish you had been
given before you took your job as you
were going around and talking to former
sections and others what did now that
you've had all this time in office what
advice do you wish someone had given you
and Julie that's questions coming to you
too but uh I'm gonna give you a little
bit of time to think about it but Mr
Secretary General so first of all I I
received a lot of good advice and all
that advice I am very good at receiving
and listening to advice so I've done
that my whole life and I and I spent a
lot of time actually traveling around
and preparing myself to become a
Secretary General NATO after I was
appointed I think in March 2014 and then
I I took up the office in on the first
of October so I had quite a long time to
prepare and that was good because that
was actually able to listen to advice
and I got a lot of good advice from
experts and and people I like like think
tanks in United States and and others
um but I think the most important advice
is that we need to keep a Europe and
North America together as whatever
happens it's very hard to predict what
would what would be next Crisis what
would be the next challenge we face but
whatever that challenge or crisis is as
long as we stand together Europe and
North America we will manage
NATO is of course important for Europe
that's uh for me obvious but it's also
important for the United States it's a
huge Advantage for the United States to
have a assertive friends and allies in
in NATO no other major power China
Russia doesn't have anything like like
that and that makes also United States
safer and stronger and in particular if
you are afraid of the size of of China
the the budgets their economy and and
also what they do now do when they come
to comes to a technology then it's it's
a great thing to have a friend's analyze
and as long as you stay together Europe
and North America we will manage
everything
well that's a wonderful answer and I I
would have thought it would have been
don't eat the Cheval
[Music]
cafeteria but uh that's the advice I
wish I had gotten I had that and then
someone told me I shouldn't have but
Julie over to you
what if I what advice you would have
received
uh it's hard uh first of all I've only
been in the seat uh for about a year and
a half so I don't feel like I have
tremendous wisdom certainly not the same
level of experience that the Secretary
General brings to Bear here each and
every day I too was given uh plenty of
terrific advice
um by folks who know NATO inside and out
like the two of you but also from former
perm reps
um a lot of stress on the importance of
listening and learning before you jump
in and I tried to heed that advice when
I came in and spend a lot of time
listening to the Allies someone said
every single voice here counts and
matters and you don't just assume that
it'll be a certain club that you'll
dictate the the Allies that you'll be
interacting with the most and I do I
interact with all of the Allies each and
every day and multiple different
configurations depending on the issue we
all bring different strength and
insights and perspectives and it's been
amazing to watch each and every Ally
bring fresh ideas and fresh thinking to
the table each time that we sit down at
The Knack I have found sometimes that
multilateral diplomacy takes a lot of
work this is a new setting for me not to
be working in a bilateral capacity but
with 30 other allies but equally what I
found to be true which I kind of knew in
my heart when I took the job was that
when 31 countries come together and make
a decision it carries enormous weight
and so the work that goes into consensus
while it sometimes takes longer than you
ever would imagine at the end of the day
the influence that comes with that
decision the power the heft of a
decision taken at 31 as we would say
really matters and it is observed and
taken seriously whether it's a a
statement or a new policy or a press
conference or whatever it is we're doing
a communique the world is watching and
so we put the time in here we fight
through some of those tough debates we
do have debates here each and every week
but I think it's it has played out in
many ways as I expected that the time is
worth reaching consensus I don't think
we should ever question consensus here
in the alliance because of what it
fundamentally means to the world and to
us to have all 31 of us agree on
something
that's a wonderful place and I know that
um the transatlantic community and
really everyone is extraordinarily
fortunate to have you both in your
current roles so thank you for all of
your leadership through
um this really
um critical time so thank you and I
guess we could end with a happy
anniversary brussels sprouts um thanks
thanks to both of you for doing it we
really appreciate it and
um yeah have a great afternoon
thank you